le président par intérim tourner le
verger vice-président également
development et finances chez gnl québec
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur fillion est ce
que c'est un coup dur que ce rapport du
bape pour votre projet écoutez c'est un
rapport qu'on attendait nous avec avec
grand intérêt puisque ça fait plus d'un
an qu'on est engagé dans le processus du
bape donc on attendait ça vraiment avec
impatience
c'est sûr que quand on regarde le
premier abord les conclusions ça peut
paraître difficile sur certains sujets
mais on a déjà eu le temps de nous de se
plonger dans le contenu est en fait
c'est un rapport qui est beaucoup plus
nuancée qui puisse paraître
qu'évidemment on a encore des devoirs
remplir mais on se rend compte aussi il
ya beaucoup d'aspects positifs qui ont
été soulevées par le bape et la
commission elle-même notamment sur la
carboneutralité les retombées
économiques et puis notre engagement
pour la protection des bélougas donc
nous on va prendre ces questions
supplémentaires et les traiter comme on
l'a fait depuis 2014 soit 10 la
commission du bape dit clairement que la
somme des risques dépassait de ces
avantages
vous devez à la lumière de ses propos là
je pose la question revoit à votre
projet mais en fait cette conclusion-là
été prises basée sur les principes de
précaution
la commission l'a traité en long en
large et en travers dans son dans son
rapport et donc c'est parce qu'il ya
encore de l'incertitude scientifique sur
certains sujets notamment sur la partie
en liaison avec la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre donc nous on va
travailler vraiment partir de maintenant
et puis je pense que le ministre
charette a été assez clair sur le sujet
également remplir ces conditions et puis
à venir avec des explications
satisfaisantes pour des différentes
parties sur ces sujets là parce que le
bape dit que le gouvernement doit tenir
pour acquis dans sa décision que votre
projet entraînerait finalement un ajout
des gaz à effet de serre une émission
supplémentaire des gaz à effet de serre
et non pas une réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mondiales comme
vous l'avez toujours prétendu depuis le
début oui donc comme je l'indiquais sur
ce sujet là la commission n'est elle
même pas en mesure de confirmer ou
d'infirmer en fait ces informations là
c'est vraiment
parce que cette industrie demande de
l'énergie aie c'est pas tout noir ou
tout blanc c'est relativement grille
donc c'est compliqué parfois est
complexe à expliquer ces choses là et
puis à trouver des certitudes
donc ça va être à nous justement de
travailler pour pour aller sur la banane
à la bonne conclusion danser dans ces
éléments là puis la la la commission
d'ailleurs précise que en fonction du
scénario on pourrait se retrouver très
bien entre une réduction de 80 millions
de tonnes voire une augmentation de 45 5
millions de tonnes en fonction du
scénario donc ça va être à nous vraiment
de faire la démonstration
je comprends mais après toutes ces
années et puis après tout les mémoires
peu près toutes ces études le bape
arrive quand même à la conclusion que le
gouvernement doit tenir pour acquis que
votre projet va émettre davantage de gaz
à effet de serre et pas le contraire et
le babc dit qu'il n'y a pas de garantie
quant à l'utilisation de votre gaz
naturel liquéfié pour remplacer des
énergies plus polluants
autrement dit ce que vous nous dites
depuis des années le bape vous dit que
vous n'avez pas été capable de le
démonter en effet pendant ces audiences
là il semblerait que les informations
qui ont été partagés ne pas été
suffisant pour que le bât puisse
confirmer cela de l'autre côté le bape
nos côtés en mesure non plus de
l'infirmer donc là nous vraiment
travailler là dessus on voit aussi que
le monde a changé depuis l'année
dernière ça va très vite notamment avec
la pandémie
vous vous donner un exemple concret
l'année dernière à l'époque du bab
l'europe notamment n'envisagez pas de m
de gaz naturel dans sa relance verte
la semaine dernière ils ont commencé à
réfléchir à le mettre dans la
réglementation dont des conditions très
particulières qui seraient justement le
remplacement d'énergie plus polluants
tels que le charbon donc on voit une
évolution aussi là dedans et donc ça va
être à nous maintenant d'amener les
nouvelles et nouveaux éléments depuis
depuis le très les travaux du bape qui
ont eu lieu l'année dernière pour pour
justement apporter les conditions
satisfaisantes aux au ministre charrette
le bape dit aussi que vous avez manqué
votre chance de sécuriser des contrats
de vente à long terme que la fenêtre
d'opportunité s'est réduite depuis
l'annnonce du projet en 2014 donc non
seulement sur le plan écologique
environnementale vous n'atteignez pas
les objectifs
mais sur le plan commercial et
économique vous avez manqué vos
opportunités vous
le bape on dirait que tous vos arguments
depuis des années ont été un peu
déconstruit par le bape sur ce sujet là
c'est important de rappeler que
évidemment on a de la concurrence sinon
la vie serait beaucoup trop facile donc
c'est à nous de jouer avec cette
concurrence là il ya plusieurs points
qui sont sûr c'est que là le demande de
gnl va croître dans les prochaines
années j'ai encore reçu ce matin un
rapport des films de consultation qui le
confirme donc il va falloir qu'on joue
nous dans ce carré sable là avec
différents différents concurrents et
compétiteur maintenant il ya deux
éléments qu'il faut pas oublier dans
cette histoire là parce qu'on l'a on
regarde la demande mais il faut pas
oublier l'approvisionnement évidemment
et en termes d'approvisionnement c'est
là qu'il ya des changements majeurs et
c'est là où le canada et notre projet le
québec peut jouer un rôle puisque
justement il ya toute cette notion de
géopolitique
quand vous allez transiger avec un pays
comme le canada
c'est beaucoup plus simple que de le
faire avec le qatar ou la russie donc
c'est un argument important est le
deuxième argument qui est également très
importante pour nos acheteurs et les
différents pays
c'est l'intensité carbone de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement c'est là aussi on se
démarque par rapport aux autres pays
essentiellement grâce aux normes
environnementales ici au québec au
canada interne sur le verger
on s'est parlé plusieurs fois la gnl
québec devenu souvent une émission j'ai
senti plus d'enthousiasmé dans le passé
là je pas certain que le bape vous amène
une dose d'entousiasme aujourd'hui sur
une échelle de 1 à 10 un état très
improbable et 10 titres improbables en
place ou le curseur sur la sueur sur le
fait que votre projet va se réaliser oui
ou non c'est une bonne question
nous on est toujours très confiant que
le projet va aller de l'avant on a des
investisseurs qui sont présents en fonde
beaucoup d'intérêt sur les marchés en
termes d'achat de gaz naturel liquéfié
mais aussi aussi d'investissement donc
soyons ne soyons pas trop optimiste en
plus leur mettant à 810 mhz et sur des
ça va se réaliser selon vous mais moi je
suis très confiant que le projet va se
réaliser avec tous les avantages que ce
projet peut apporter l heureux qu'on
peut jouer sur la planète je suis très
très confiant
merci monsieur les vergers merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit